cours de formation géographiques et
sociales cinquième année aujourd'hui les
ports un port est un abri naturel ou
créés par l'homme qui est aménagé pour
recevoir les navires leur chargement et
permettre le débarquement de leur
chargement en fonction du site choisi
pour leur installation les porcs peuvent
être classés en deux catégories tout
d'abord les ports maritimes qui sont
situés en façade de mer sur les côtes
comme le port de singapour ou de calais
évidemment les zones comme des capes ou
des baies sont des points plus
avantageux que simplement une ligne de
côte rectiligne et nous avons dans un
deuxième temps les ports fluviaux situés
sur les fleuves comme le port de
gennevilliers près de paris
le port de hambourg en allemagne ou
encore le port de l'autre le port
d'estuaire se situe un peu entre le port
maritime et le port fluvial
pour rappel l'estuaire c'est
l'embouchure d'un fleuve qui se termine
en forme d'entonnoir comme ici
l'estuaire de l'escaut sur l'image
satellite qui vous est proposé ici on
peut constater qu'il y à trois port
le premier le plus important c'est le
port d'anvers qui est lui typiquement un
port d'estuaire puisqu'il est au fin
fond en fonds d'estuaires de l'escaut
vous voyez que les bateaux ici pour
quitter le port vont devoir suivre le
cours de l'escaut
il est d'ailleurs intéressant de noter
que dans cet estuaire
il ya certains problèmes qui vont
apparaître de sédimentation donc c'est à
dire de dépôt des petits éléments
puisque vous voyez ici j'ai des bancs
plus clair qu'ils apparaissent c'est
sans doute les bancs de sable ou de
selim ans qui viennent se déposer ici et
donc qui cause problème pour la
navigation
l'image qui vous est proposé est
intéressante puisqu'il y à d'autres
ports si je remonte ici le cours de la
lys je vais arriver sur la ville de gand
mais vous voyez ici des petites
structures mais indique la présence de
quai et de rad qui permettent
d'identifier le port de gants ici on est
clairement en face à un port fluvial
enfin ici plus au nord même s'il n'est
pas à front de mer le port de new york à
un accès presque direct à la mer et on
pourrait le considérer
afin d'avoir sur cette image les trois
catégories de porcs qu'il s'agit d'un
port maritime
mais évidemment il suffit ici il s'agit
plus d'un port de sortie d'estuaire
dans un contexte de commerce mondialisé
où les échanges entre les différentes
parties du monde sont de plus en plus
important les ports joue un rôle
essentiel puisqu'ils permettent le
transport de grandes quantités de
marchandises mais les ports d'estuaire
sont véritablement encore plus
avantageux puisque il constitue
véritablement des noeuds pour le compte
commerce mondial on entend par ne le
fait qu'ils vont pouvoir être vraiment
la jonction entre différents réseaux et
si il y à un transport maritime par
exemple qui arrivent au port de
rotterdam grâce à l'estuaire dont le
fond duquel il se situe le port de
rotterdam va permettre justement de
continuer les échanges par le transport
fluvial cette fois ci via le rhin via la
meuse et de rejoindre le sud de l'europe
ce qui est très avantageux vous verrez
d'ailleurs que ici j'ai le port de
duisbourg on a parlé tout à l'heure
évidemment il va y avoir chaque fois des
plateformes comme ça modal qui vont
permettre de partir sur les réseaux
routiers donc les ports et les ports
fluviaux aussi sont des noeuds qui
permette vraiment aux marchandises
d'arriver aux territoires les plus
enclavées
l'ani la navigation sur les maires ne
connaît quasi pas de limites
si ce n'est des limites techniques par
contre dans les estuaires et sur les
fleuves il y a une limite très direct
qui va empêcher certains navires de
naviguer il s'agit du tirant d'eau
le tirant d'eau d'un bateau et
l'enfoncement maximale du bateau que
l'on que peut accepter une voie d'eau
sur le schéma qui vous est proposé ici
c'est la partie rouge du dessin
le tirant d'eau correspond donc à la
hauteur de la partie immergée du bateau
qui varie en fonction de la charge
transportée évidemment plus la charge
transportée va être importante plumes en
tirant d'eau sera important le tirant
d'eau d'un cours d'eau correspond à la
hauteur maximale entre la surface de
l'eau et le fond du cours d'eau
évidemment si le tirant d'eau de mon
avenir est trop important ben je risque
tout simplement de toucher le fond du
cours d'eau et je ne pourrai plus
naviguer afin d'augmenter le tirant
d'eau et ainsi permettre à des plus gros
navires de passer on peut effectuer des
dragages donc si il s'agit d'enlever de
la matière au fond du cours d'eau pour
permettre le passage de plus gros
navires
la sédimentation et le processus par
lequel les petits éléments vont se
déposer au fond des cours d'eau ou au
fond des océans
les cours d'eau avant d'arriver à la mer
ont de moins en moins de force et donc
vont déposer les petits éléments qu'ils
transportaient jusque là les marais
peuvent à la fois jouer un rôle positif
en emmenant tous les éléments qui sont
déposés à l'entrée du des stups de
l'estuaire ou alors carrément venir en
déposer de nouveau ce qui pose problème
puisque petit à petit l'estuaire et le
cours d'eau vont se combler et ils ne
permettront plus le passage des plus
gros navires qui nécessite un grand
tyran d'où le processus naturel de
sédimentation empêche donc la bonne
tenue de la navigation sur les estuaires
et certains cours d'eau les hommes pour
continuer à naviguer vont opérer à un
dragage il s'agit de l'enlèvement des
matières qui sont dans la dans le fond
d'une surface dos d'une étendue d'eau
pour approfondir cette étendue où ce
cours d'eau les matières récupérées vont
être réutilisés pour gagner de nouveaux
terrains de nouveaux espaces sur les
océans et sur l'eau
c'est de cette manière que les pays bas
ont pu agrandir leur superficie utile ça
fera l'objet d'une prochaine vidéo que
vous retrouvez sur blu géo et sur la
chaîne youtube
à bientôt